[Music]
all I have for you is a word
[Music]
it'll open the right doors some of the
wrong ones to use it carefully to do
what I do I need some idea of the threat
we face as I understand it we're trying
to prevent World War 3 I'm not saying
I'm again something was I can't do you
have an interest in a certain national
like spring man
you can communicate with the future
tap trouble no inversion a mitten in
poetry you know shooting the bullet you
know catching it
what I've seen too much my work try and
Cooper
community transcends national interests
this is about survival
seems whoa hold up find that I were
gonna say nuts
where
how would you like to die oh you chose
the wrong profession
[Music]
I know that some here has it happened
yet
there are people in the future when he
does
I'm a tenant
we need to save them here and now
this reversing the flow of time wasn't
us being here now it never happened
[Music]
you want to crash a plane but not from
the air no such visor well having a
plane that part is a little dramatic
[Music]
your instructor is one of the finest
pilots this program has ever produced
[Music]
his exploits are legendary what he has
to teach you may very well mean the
difference between life and death your
reputation precedes you
after admit I wasn't expecting an
invitation back
they're called orders
[Music]
this is your captain speaking
today's exercise is dogfighting
two-person one oh you've got to be
kidding
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
you know what a courtesy tap is young
man it sounds like this it's like
friendly I'm sure that's what your mom
meant to you no it's not mom
having a kind of a hard time later I'm
sorry
accept my apology Sakura
you could just do the same we could
press reset I don't have anything to
apologize for
[Music]
can you go please
ma'am are you okay I'm pretty sure the
guy in that trucks following me these
road-raging
want you just chill man go your own way
I don't think you really know what a bad
day is
she will find out
that man stole my phone Eddie I'm
sitting here and waiting for you whose
phone is on I crossed me friend
hey listen to me he's not a friend okay
he's the psycho who came after me today
this is where your first lesson begins
no I can't do that
I need you learn what a bad day really
is I need you to learn how to say sorry
yeah you're gonna learn to fine on some
retribution you better bring your A game
you're gonna eat it
my life doesn't be what you probably
think it has we all have our struggles
have you ever been left a long long time
ago you so many times yeah all the time
[Music]
welcome to the future
life is good but it can be better why
shouldn't it be
all you need to work
think about finally having everything
you always wanted
I can see today
I take what I want in return
everyone will see
[Applause]
I'll need you
you know you need to do
[Music]
nothing good is born from lies
and greatness is not what you think
[Music]
Oh art ah that's just this trash it's
just a trash can yeah yeah I tell people
my sister moved out west
their science teacher your husband he
renovate houses you're thinking about
moving but you're gonna waits until the
interest rates go down that's all my
story boy who's an Avenger
I mean mistakes
[Applause]
and a lot of enemies
is called Symes taskmaster
he controls the Red Room they're
manipulated fully conscious but no
choices I should have come back for you
how many others are there Thanos
[Applause]
we have to go back to where it all
started so they never do that to anyone
again
we're Emily fight with you
you won't win
look look it's the past
okay you go to plan what shall I just
say Doug encode my plan was to drive us
away where your plan sucks
[Music]
at some point we all have to choose
I mean with the world wants you to be
[Music]
and me my choice
I need I'm running
[Music]
here's what's gonna happen Natasha don't
slouch
I'm not slouching you're going to get
the back hunched listen to mother oh my
god
all right enough all of you I didn't say
anything that's not fair my flock this
will not be a war of Heels nations well
slaughter each other while we get to
play
this is going to be fun
[Applause]
you cannot keep me locked away as the
world burns son the truth is the world
is ruled by corruption and greed we must
do something
certainly
[Music]
we are the first independent
intelligence agency refined but brutal
civilized but Messrs
welcome to the club Harris fellow it's
time to pour fuel
the fire of revolution yes I should
welcome Englishman Rasputin your
reputation precedes you
[Music]
what send this as gentlemen after all
-
make mine
[Music]
why is it the boys are always so messy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Mondays am i right Joe you said it guy
don't have a good day have a great day
hey bud you ever think that there's got
to be more more than what stuff we do it
day after day being shot at run over
taken hostage today's gonna be different
hi this isn't you you don't do this man
Harry he's just resting and please if
that man is dead
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
is this what recreational drugs feel
like guy this world it's a video game
and it's full of bad guys I'm a rule
breaker I'm a rattlesnake guy
we need you to be good good guy
giddyup
is that a Glock in your pocket know what
it's 2 bucks
[Music]
I'm not gonna be the good guy I'm gonna
be the great guy okay
well enjoy your lifetime supply of
virginity you go
clothes organics six of our northern
cities have fallen in a coordinated
attack their leader fights alongside a
witch
crush these murderers your majesty every
family must contribute one man to fight
your war hero you've already made many
great sacrifices
my father cannot fight so I will take
his place the northern invaders will
kill her if I expose how power all
people will kill her when we take the
Imperial City I will take revenge for my
father what is your name soldier
Wai ghin commander sono Kajal you will
now take the oath of the warrior
[Music]
pretending to be something you're not
yet here I stand proof that there is a
place for people like us
a girl threatens our place
a warrior
[Applause]
[Music]
is this Clark this interstellar coming I
don't see Clark oh maybe he's still
sleeping
dad expected to enter our atmosphere
that's right now know what they say
understand where are you going I don't
know
when first chance is about to hit it's
only part of it it's gonna shoot but you
look at that what is the explosion we
now are getting word that the fragment
has gets Central Florida
wait are some more pieces gonna hit come
on let's go
two days they got it along there's a ton
of fragment mana killer space agencies
are predicting an extinction level event
we're gonna be together all right good
just try to get to safety
they've been tracking the military
flights to bunkers in Greenland
certainly shots
[Music]
I get my family if you are hearing this
broadcast seek shelter immediately what
is it what's wrong
what's the last thing you remember
Danny he said we had to route the reason
you survived it's because you're a very
uncommon girl you're not alone not
anymore
do you know how mutants are would anyone
like to she had their first time brain I
was 13 I thought it was a dream I just
lost control Sam I started panicking
people got hurt
Liberto my girlfriend a partner Ilyana
I killed 18 men one by one
[Music]
this isn't a hospital it's a cage
[Music]
it's important we find out your collar
so we can help you get better
I saw something I don't think you wanted
me to see
I don't think we're here to get better
this place takes your greatest fear and
later lived through it until it kills
you
he's there we can get out of this
together
[Applause]
[Music]
Michael I've learned you since you were
a child we have a gift
you always have if there's an answer to
the disease we'll find it
I should have died years ago
why am I still here if not to fix this I
have a rare blood disease and I'm not
that at a time
this could be my last chance
you're up to something what is it
that's not exactly label
I want to see you get hurt more than you
already have this would be a cure
at what cost
[Music]
I went from time
of increased strength his speed
the ability is echolocation
an overpowering urge to consume blood
[Music]
how far are we allowed to go
we'll fix something that's broken
until the remedy
is worse than the disease
Michael Morbius attentive doing a little
good guy paying up what's up doc
just
[Applause]
[Music]
you get the truck come back with the
money that's two point five million
dollars per head if you come back alive
Travis compiled
I just took it out on me
[Music]
music
dr. das right
[Music]
[Music]
so what are you doing out here there is
a legend in the jungles of the Amazon of
a tree that heals or it could change the
world but if it gets into the wrong
hands it could awaken a great evil I
believe that the legend is real dudes
man I'm gonna find edgy wall when I do
just imagine the lives that could be
saved I've been looking for this tree
longer than anybody I've tracked the
legend to every village every island
nothing researching for something that
can't be found
but you've never had the key let's do
something that's safe let's go see some
elephants they're all no elephants in
the Amazon and I don't even like
elephants lady everybody likes velvet
know this about the jungle
everything that you see wants to kill
you and can
careful take a smell fear
Oh My Goddess
who brings a submarine to the Amazon oh
yeah
[Music]
goodnight
Oh
[Music]
forget it come on okay I don't got it
goes away
[Music]
what are you doing here in Somerville
anyway honestly my mom won't say it but
we're completely broke any honest thing
that's left in our name this is creepy
old farmhouse my grandfather left us in
the middle of nowhere
why'd you bring me up here entertain
without you what is that somehow a town
that isn't anywhere near a tectonic
plate that has no fault lines no
fracking no loud music even is shaking
on a daily basis
I remember that one summer we died on
our table I found this in my living room
Oh killer replica a replica of what a
ghost trap there hasn't been a ghost
sighting in 30 years New York in the 80s
it's like The Walking Dead your dad
never mentioned this team it's just my
mom my grandfather died my mom says
we're just here to pick through the Rob
loves life
[Music]
who are you
call it a
[Music]
call it lock
call it karma
that everything happens for a reason
come on darlin
it has a connor seat
[Music]
[Music]